the country has gone into a nihilistic
fever that's why I'm thinking we gotta
hit the road and get out for traveling
across America to find what makes
America tick the Charlatans the geniuses
of American Hero
this is it we found the point around
which Hollywood has gone insane we're
starting west where the myth is we're
gonna head east into the swamp we're
going into the belly of the beast I
think I wanna leave now doesn't get any
more guns over this we may be completely
different by the end of this journey
this is Florida man country yeah Florida
man is famous world famous because any
time like the freakiest of the freaky
happens in America you can count on it
being Florida man yeah Florida man that
song as the lead on a on a news story
isn't it it could be Colorado man or New
York man or California man but usually
if it's a freaky story it starts a
Florida man Florida man jumps into a
pool of alligators jumps out and then
jumps back in that happened just today
so we were googling this we went Florida
man and we're heading to st. Augustine
and there's Florida man jumps into pool
of alligators at alligator Park in st.
Augustine we're trying to speculate why
that is I mean California they say is
full of crazy people because they all
end up rolling in to California and then
they grohl across the country and then
they stop at California but with red
that yeah it was Florida
remember in Midnight Cowboy they were
heading to Florida like that was the
promised land it's sunny all the time
and it's got some appeal and somehow it
attracts every crazy person in the
country we are so in neatly as Americans
embarrassed about Florida that we said
that is Plymouth Rock fact the first
settlement by Europeans was here in st.
Augustine Florida Florida man was
Florida man before there was math yeah
Florida man would be struck out on our
son Florence Doodle from I would
actually diary New Jersey another
surrounded by real oranges sang official
orange drink of the space program
artificial smell made in a factory
Erika's prayed at the altar artificiales
Kerry condition nightmare fed on a diet
of propane and diet pills shucking
oysters and shooting smack that's the
way the political establishment paired
the ground war domination of
surveillance technology located in every
every stir a Roland cartridge
[Music]
web pages of all within the context
having lost all imagination you're
becoming more and more hunters Thompson
as we go along
you see there's blue skies up ahead we
went through the cleansing the laundry
and now we're on the other side and it's
all blue skies again we've been baptized
now we are ready to embrace our inner
Florida man and Florida woman selves oh
my god if we jump into an alligator pit
and that's how this ends
[Music]
[Applause]
the original swamp Stacy st. Augustine
it's the perfect place to end
are we ready to surrender to Florida
ma'am
do embrace our inner Florida man you
know we learned a lot on this journey
max we basically learned that we hail
from swamp
we are swamp and no matter what the
swamp shines through you don't need a
linear thought in this town or this
country or this universe just go with
what you know go with the flow only dead
fish go with the stream you got to fight
the stream spawn up did the place of
your birth and this is where we were all
born
we're haunted by the past being chased
back to the swamp from which we all came
I failed that chase hot breath of the
past breathing down my neck daily trying
to pull me back into the whether it's
the la brea tar pit in Los Angeles or
the swamp of st. Augustine it's that
center of the earth the gravitational
force pulling on hope you can't hide the
swamp it's real stinky and it's real
murky but basically all life at one
point crawled out of the swamp
oh it's stinky but it's stinky good all
that's righteous comes out of the murk
and the depths nothing really great come
out of something that's pure virginal
white that's not where it's all
happening happens down in the dirt
stinky stink that's where that good
stuff is all about that's why your
jacket by the end of this journey is
quite stinky
[Applause]
[Music]
outside again spice nice cool cart yard
now
it's a beautiful hello hi I'm Stacy
I'm Susan nice to meet you yes nice
isn't max nice to meet you too the
oldest house that's what we claim might
not be technically - well I'm a I'm a
historian so I'm always skeptical no we
have we have documentation that it was
standing here in the 1720s so it could
be older than that before that it was
st. Augustine Ian monks that lived here
no that's that's an old advertisement
that was made up a hundred years ago and
is incorrect now now across the street
was the monastery they were across the
street but no that's an advertisement
point in 1910 or something like that was
it fake man it was fake news yes
everywhere we've gone across America
there's always like legends and ghosts
and made-up stories
selling tourists on coming to this town
yeah I've I've worked here a long time
as a historian and it's it's kind of
interesting the mix between
doing doing history selling history and
then the history of selling history the
history of selling history is interest
which is which is a whole different
aspect well this is what we've been
doing on our journey is looking at the
history of this country and much of it
was actually myth it was kind of
exaggerated and well even Max's family
were sold by William Penn got a lot of
Germans to come over to Pennsylvania and
the act they actually put posters in the
palace tonight region of Germany that
said it was like shangri-la and
everybody arrived half them died because
it was actually a swamp that happened to
an awful lot of people I mean in the
same situation you know they would
either lure them over they they get over
here as indentured servants and they
didn't they didn't survive it and the
other thing was you know that not only
did they put them there they hardly ever
had enough supplies to feed people let
me show you around because this is the
oldest house in Florida dates from the
1720s but the grounds don't look old at
all and it's not what they would have
been at the time now we were in New
Orleans and you mentioned you're
familiar with New Orleans but one thing
we found was that it was a catholic city
surrounded by all sort of protestant
areas right and became very decadent you
could of course like commit all sorts of
sins on thursday friday and saturday
night and then go to confession and say
you know be forgiven for your sins so
what st. Augustine with the Spanish
Catholics that they seemed a little bit
more austere than the French ones
running they were a little more austere
but when but when Florida and of course
st. Augustine became part of the United
States in the early 1820s the Americans
I mean there's just this surge of
Americans that wanted to you know get
rich in Florida on what land selling
cotton things like that okay but they
they really did not like the Catholic
practices in st. Augustine and we had a
very minor Mardi Gras carnival yeah you
know and they talked about how decadent
it was and editor of the newspaper who
was northern you know complained about
this sort of they would have this pseudo
burial you know they'd march to the
street with the coffin and things like
and he and the northern editor of the
brand-new newspaper
complained about this so the next time
they had there was a coffin parade they
put the editor in the coffin not the
editor effigy of the editor and March to
mark him down the street is that gonzo
journalism
yeah that's become sounds like 20th
century journalism where the facts don't
matter really it's about the story of
the story well how did you put it the
history of the history and the history
of doing history the history of doing
history I mean that's not the history of
selling history the history that sounds
gonzo journalism in a way doesn't it
well you have you know you have to
appeal to what people I mean you know
look look how Pirates have become so
important in in visitation and things
such as that they weren't always that
that that that attractive photogenic and
actually I did an article two weeks ago
about being on the other side being on
the receiving end of a pirate and what
it felt like you know if you want to
play pirate you'd better be the pirate
and not be the not be the people they're
attacking that's their the antihero
element to the Pirates right because the
Pirates are seen as heroic and they're
now in Hollywood as being these fabulous
guys who you know are cute and so this
is revision this is the history of
selling history once again it definitely
says so as historian and you know we've
been as you point out there's this
history it's very hard to find the real
history from the the soul history the
fake history and trying to find like an
American identity and it seems very
elusive kind of quarry to find something
that really represents the American
character and your Nestorian and how
would you describe let's say the
American character how would I describe
the American character you know from the
start we were told that Americans are
exceptional I'm not so sure we're all
that exceptional and most of us learn
and maybe never learn much more just
because they don't have to learn our
history in schools and history as it's
taught in school is largely done to
encourage patriotism which I'm not
opposed to patriotism but that's not the
same thing
history because it tends to be a very
one-sided perspective what do you think
about this trend recently to erase
history especially some of the southern
history and history of the the
Confederate and the Confederate Army
there yes thoughts on this I have you
know ambivalent feelings about that of
they're dueling feelings I think if you
erase too much you or people don't
realize it ever happened which means
like which means they're not they're not
aware if it happens again they don't
wreck they don't recognize it but I also
just recently served on the Confederate
monument committee here to Tec
contextualize it put in a historical
context I think that's a good idea to
put it into context as we had some
pushback but you know that there are
multiple sides to it and we talked about
you know the the Confederate war debt to
whom the monument is dedicated but also
that the Emancipation Proclamation was
probably read 20 feet from where the
Confederate monument would be put about
ten years later yeah this is the oldest
settlement in the country but these are
not the oldest buildings in the country
no they're not the oldest buildings in
the country and we can thank the English
for burning the town more than once for
that and also a hurricane or two
all right Eric yes great to catch up
with you likewise likewise so why don't
you just give us a breakdown what
exactly do you do so I am a supervisory
agent law enforcement agent for a
federal government I've been there for
12 years I've switched agencies I've
been with the feds for about 15 years
total and before that I worked for the
Sheriff's Department in Los Angeles
versus PI what do you think when you see
when you see something like this I would
have to actually ask the individual what
their purpose their integers I don't I
don't make assumptions
I see the Confederate flag and you know
some people would assume or as an
african-american man I automatically
take offense to it well I would ask the
individual well you know what's the
intent behind the flag
I mean without any preconceived notions
let's just talk about it I'm open to it
I mean because I've actually seen people
with flags that I've gone up to and had
great conversations with so it's not an
automatic deal-breaker but say oh you've
got a confederate flag where you and I
stand on two different sides of the
situation
well the mood in the country right now
seems to be to associate confederate
flag with aberrant behavior so there's a
real movement out there in the country
to get rid of this past and to associate
these images and symbols with something
that's completely unacceptable how do
you weigh in on that I think that once
again it's I don't think anyone's ever
bothered to ask what the Confederate
flag means to those who wave it proudly
it's that mean the American flag I mean
there's some people right clearly right
now that have issues with the American
flag with the star-spangled banner once
again it has that that's the discussion
that has to be so as it gets back to
what we were saying about the identity
of the country yeah a lot of people have
a different completely different view of
the country from their point of view
yeah a completely different view of what
the country is all about
and I think what we're saying also is
that at the moment it's really difficult
to define a common ground and that
ability to define that common ground is
challenged even more because of the
militarization of the police like any
even the right to assemble to have a
conversation about what the common
ground is considered potentially a
threat in a criminal activity right so
these rights are being impinged upon
it's a very unhealthy direction do you
have hope is there hope for the future
what how do you look ahead yes I do hold
on to hope because without hope what do
we have I mean I believe hope is what
inspires us to continue to invoke change
and without hope I would not be doing
what I do and I would not have impacted
the people who I've seen changing just
from my rear and interaction with them
whether it be the the young man who I
could have arrested I caught a young man
with an entire backpack full of copper
wire that he just stole from a
construction site and I had to make a
choice was I better to teach him a
lesson right there and figure out if I
could change his mentality or I could
ruin his life and put him in jail and
yeah that's exactly without event he
would have felony convictions and he
wouldn't been able get a job he actually
worked for the company that he stole it
from caught him at night and asked him
so what's going on why are you in this
circumstance what's going on that you're
stealing this wire he told me I could
not make my rent this month I'm getting
ready getting evicted I have two
children and I'm a single dad I'm not
making excuses I made a terrible
decision I said well now your decisions
10 times worse because you're going to
lose your kids you're gonna go to jail
you're gonna lose your job and you're
gonna get felony convictions so I'm
gonna put you in the back of the car and
you could think about that for 15
minutes but I do paperwork and I'll take
you to jail and he sat back there and he
cried he cried he cried and then 15
minutes later I took him out the car
took the handcuffs off I said today is
your lucky day
i'ma let you go you're gonna put the
wire back if I ever see you're doing it
again you're absolutely going to jail
for this crime as well as the new crime
but there was a lesson to be learned
there right and so he's having a good
day but I would imagine that you also
appreciated the chance from time to time
breathing a little bit having some rule
for a different outcome than just a
cutting dry you broke the law you're
going to jail type of thing so you you
also had a moment there of humanity if
you want absolutely and that that's
really what drought what drives me to be
in law enforcement is the officer
discretion officer discretion is a very
powerful tool and I tell my agents to
work for me I said what is the most
powerful weapon you have and you know
some people rattle off at the baton a
gun I got my hands again yeah officer
presence it's know your your your
biggest tool is officer discretion that
is your most powerful weapon is officer
discretion that video by Chris Rock how
not to go to jail right it was it was
very profound it was it was comedic but
it on the same note hit a lot of strong
points I mean if you don't want to go to
jail don't do what you have to do to go
to jail it's that simple
it sounds very elementary but there's a
lot of truth to that it's you know but
you believe in some sort of redemption
because you were talking about the
Confederate flag and you would talk to
that guy sure here you saw a guy doing a
bad thing stealing somebody else's
property and yet you saw that he it was
possible for him to redeem himself we
have a sort of moment right now in this
country where you do see people wanting
to just deep platform people with ugly
ideas or opinions and anybody who posts
the meme of Pepe the Frog there there's
never any good to come from talking to
them which again on the micro level
seems ridiculous when we have whole
state departments to go talk to bad guys
across the world or you know in order to
communicate and like find a common
ground absolutely don't be a bad guy
okay and doesn't it feel like we we
should talk more absolutely and that's
really what it comes down to is a lot of
these situations can be resolved with
conversation we need to understand where
people come from and we need to respect
differences it doesn't mean that we're
going to go at the end of the day but we
can respect that you have an opinion I
have an opinion and what makes this
country great is that we're allowed to
have those opinions because in some
countries you don't get an opinion and
if you do express your opinion it's
going to result in serious consequence
exactly and it often seems like maybe
they're bad at
is based on mis-education or being fed
bad ideas are only listening to one sort
of opinion so if they if that guy with a
confederate flag
here's your side of the story surely
your story growing up he might or she
might think something different
absolutely I'm a flip side if you ever
had any like patently dirty hairy
moments right what's gonna be punk you
know that type of thing sure yes that's
a whole other episode right there yes
buddy yes there's plenty of
opportunities to talk about those yes
okay yeah what would you count a
suspicious activity by Florida man does
everything he does
[Music]
these are huge look at that one over
there this is where Florida man jumped
in does it go through your mind here I'm
looking at these and go hey gee I wonder
what it would be like to jump in there
and go hang out with these alligators oh
they're fighting oh my god this is like
being in the halls of Congress these are
the swamp creatures that rule us
they're just slugs just lying there in
wait ready to pounce on any dime you
make they're like turning into humans
and humans turning into these alligators
the back and forth through hundreds
hundreds of millions of years of time we
have DNA that we share with them they
have DNA they share with us as some
molecular cellular level where we're
equal we're part of each other but
they're completely still and they are
drawing us in you know 30 American
alligators again and this is hunter
country
longest alligators in here he's ready
for food I guess out he looks like he's
smiling at you now he's looking at me
guys make sure to sell this to the news
if I get eaten open your mouth
Hunter hunter Hunter hunter come on what
that was good that was perfect that sure
[Music]
all the way up behind the back leg I'm a
hair all the way keep going so this is
what happened to Hunter as Thompson
after he got shot out of the cannon
hunter he's been reincarnated oh my god
max it's gonna be eaten by hunters
Thompson's reincarnated as an alligator
max how you feeling nervous
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
so you got us some publicity I see
Florida man takes selfie with Gator
impressive and that's in the daily
Florida man Wow I went on the journey
knowing that I would be was a cathartic
journey and I would see America for what
it really is and it all happened you
know we made fun of Florida man and then
we realized that that is America
Trump is America so now you are Florida
man I'm fused with my spirit animal the
alligator you know we are in the pit
there with hunter and and now I see it I
see where this is all going now I and I
understand how Abra fits in because
without that crypto wallet we can't all
come together like we need to that's
this that's the beauty of it so you are
Florida man now just to be clear until
you get into the pit with alligators you
really don't understand Florida man and
therefore you don't understand America I
may never understand Florida man as a
result but I love the publicity the
other thing we learned is that you can't
drain the swamp it's impossible because
once you get to the swamp you become one
with the alligators and you become the
swamp it's hard to describe but until
you see what it's like to be with the
alligators
yeah you cannot appreciate alligator man
and Florida man and therefore our
president and therefore the voters of
this country wow what a trip
yeah right sure you know we're getting
ready for the next you know series and
you know we saw of America kind of what
it's all about
well yeah it definitely comes from the
swamp and it lives in a swamp and it's
about entrepreneurialism within the
swamp and now it's not the globe you
know we're thinking maybe Africa Europe
Asia we're not sure I mean what do you
where do you where would you recommend
where are we gonna take the abra message
that gorillas in the mist
silly right I think we should find as
many animals as we can for you to put
t-shirts on that involve you putting
your life at great personal risk we're
ready and I'm in the car I'm looking
forward to the car right
well done Florida man excellent all
right all right belt right oh my god
Florida man manifest destiny and the
second term was American exceptionalism
in these two terms go together because
they inform certain elite mindset that
suggests that anything that gets in the
way a quote progress read white people
is to be destroyed and of course the
first wave went west and it killed all
the native populations then the next
wave went south and it killed all the
black African population now the third
wave is the final wave is the wing that
will kill all the white people because
they've run out of everybody else to
wave over with their manifest destiny an
American exceptionalism
um
quiet now trying to take all this
information in that I'm actually Florida
woman I this is profound this
information this insights we've had and
we have arrived at the truth
I think we haven't arrived at a truce
finally they put a Florida man in the
white house it's a great moment of ever
in America there's the triumphant
Florida man over over everything you
know really nothing else needs to be
said because those are the final words
of gonzo we are Florida man we're all
Florida man I think that's a fitting pin
[Music]
this is my Dominion Florida man and
I am king of the alligators they do what
I say I am Florida man
they don't seem convinced
[Music]